alright are you ready for some pre-roll
sure some some banter before the video
starts like what's a what's a good
banter banter um banter by the way Jerry
i [ __ ] your mom that's that's a tip
what no dancer
hello guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
so today we're talking about crimson
peak crimson peak bling crimson peaked
and hit puberty the positives are pretty
much the same positives that everyone on
YouTube everyone on rotten tomatoes
anyone who's anyone is saying this the
visuals are great yeah i mean the movie
is gorgeous to look at the sets are
incredible i'm wondering how many these
are like constructed sets versus actual
Gothic style homes or buildings just cuz
some of them do look very real and very
well I heard that I heard that least the
you know the haunted home was built oh
just Alice movie yeah the haunted house
has such a personality to the film
another the common thing and it's what
we said right when the movie was done
was that this movie is totally miss
marketed it's it not a [ __ ] horror
movie well and Guillermo del Toro has
said that a few times I've found since
we saw it like I saw some interviews
with him yeah he's like this isn't a
horror movie its Gothic romance beware
crimson peaks trailer put this cat is
yeah so distracting for the review if
you look at the crimson peak trailer
they really want you to believe this is
a horror movie and they put most of the
ghost scenes in that trailer at least
partially so that's very misleading and
the thing is they put most of the go
scenes and there's not a lot of go
scenes it says you have to think this is
gonna be like a pan's labyrinth or a
Hellboy worth like there will be
creatures yeah lot and and there aren't
its norm just a direct human story about
it is a Gothic romance about Tom
Hiddleston and Mia wachowski was a cow
skin wasikowska what is that some type
of eel mirror or the Mia no it's it's a
name mia wasikowska and tom hiddleston
they fall in love but something is up
but Tom Hiddleston we don't quite know
what he's up to yeah there's something
dubious it seems like going on at least
you know within the mystery of who he is
and what his circumstances are and and
the this the speed at which they
developed this romance see that's where
I'm wondering was this intentional for
it to be misleading first off they do
say in the movie oh I'm writing a story
but it's about it's about the people and
the ghosts or just happen to be in it
yeah Mia Wasikowska character is a
writer and she's working on some kind of
a novel and it features ghost
a lot and people keep basically telling
her to shoehorn a romance into it and
that the ghosts are you know horror
she's like no no there the more metaphor
for the past and stuff like that she's
trying to write a heavier book than
women were allowed to ride at the time
but she even says like it's not a ghost
story it's just there are ghosts in it
and that's pretty much where crimson
peak is like to yeah is it's not a ghost
story but it does feature ghosts it's
not about a haunting so much like the
haunting is circumstantial it's like
those all still linked back to the
people the people are more horrific than
the ghosts there's more of a fairy tale
vibe to it than an actual horror vibe
and I think that when it comes to the
ghosts that was that he knows one of the
top thinks I was complaining about when
I was I was like there's no point for
these ghosts to be in there they I still
disagree with that I get I get what
you're saying and I don't like entirely
disagree it's like if you took out the
ghosts I don't think the movie would be
the same you'd still need something else
to go there some of the time yeah but I
don't think it needs to be such a
separate entity like a supernatural
thing like something more natural and
could have happened yeah letter to such
events yeah I mean these kinds of
stories like these gothic stories
they're not always a horrific or go
sleep but ghosts are at home in stories
like this I'm not upset that they're
there they're just so much bigger than
the rest of the movie and the
advertising I do kind of think the
advertising has [ __ ] us for this whole
movie experience because if I had seen
it cold I don't know if I would have
this problem but the trailers like
[ __ ] ghost look on here about dr. o
design it looks like a horror it's more
like domestic violence as opposed to an
actual like ghosts haunting attacking
people story you know is that's not what
happens in the film well yeah it's not a
haunting like these are these are
spirits that are that are to their
spirits or ghosts with personalities or
characters well I think it might be
maybe not Guillermo del Toro's problem
maybe it might be our perception or
preconceived notions like I have [ __ ]
with the experience of this movie yeah
like I've seen trailers where I'm like
okay bad trailer or poor representation
but I still get the movie this is one
where I feel like it's not even a
quality expectation it's like a Content
it's like I thought there were going to
be lots of ghosts and everyone
thought they were gonna be lots of
ghosts and everyone thought it was gonna
be a horror movie and this isn't the
kind of a story we get a lot anymore
especially in cinema so I feel like the
trailer has kind of [ __ ] up the movie
I would have killed to see it with no
trailer I would I don't even really
remember the trailer that much but I do
what everybody remembers go everybody
remembers ghosts and but the sad thing
is is like although the ghosts are not
necessary they were still the most
interesting part of the film to me when
they were on screen like yes them scenes
were scary with them absolutely there
weren't a lot of them but I was mainly
intrigued as to more about them and
what's going on with them because the
actual human tail that we get I thought
was very predictable very obvious the
things that they shoot as reveals like
I'm not sure I don't think they shot
them as reveals and that's part of the
weirdness that my problem with it was
everything was so apparent and obvious
and I felt like I was a million times
smarter than the main character I felt
like I wasn't on this journey with her I
didn't think I'm smarter than her I just
felt like they gave me a lot more
information and then we're sort of
watching her get all the way to the
point that we are at like yeah as the
movie doesn't ever make an attempt to or
at least it didn't feel to me to hide
any of the things that's why they don't
feel like reveals all the twists and and
and sort of things that are on on things
that are revealed about the true nature
of certain people in certain situations
all the performances suggest these
things the movie don't ever try to hide
it but it doesn't go out of its way to
make it clear until the last half hour
of this film that's when like the
reveals have everything that the stuff
where ya know whatever is like what the
[ __ ] oh my god I'm like really I knew
that like 45 minutes ago and they were
having clear about it yeah we were
starting to suspect things you know
pretty early on and and the plot does
move ahead in this weird way where it's
like they don't spend forever on one
idea like the plot without giving
anything away it's hard uh you know the
plot develops in a way that actually
kind of makes sense just getting from
like point A to B to C to D to E to F to
G like just in terms of this yeah the
immediate story I do agree
in a sense it's not altogether
satisfying and sometimes it's not
engaging it's not that some reason a lot
of the drama isn't that compelling
because it's like if you don't make
these things a mystery we have to have
something else to hold on to because if
we know where the story is going before
it's gotten there you got to give us
something else yeah I don't blame it for
doing that cuz you don't have to then
again these are the kinds of things that
happen in Gothic romance and these kinds
of stories these are the kinds of
characters that populate these worlds
but we do I think need another thing to
make it more thrilling yes yes I'm more
engaging like don't get me wrong that I
think the performances are really good
Tom Hiddleston every time he was on
screen I was really interested yeah he
was fantastic to watch yeah jessica
chastain I don't I'm still not sure how
I felt about her performance I thought
you know I because I've disliked little
to like you is like she was performing I
thought I would go that way but the more
time went on like this is a role that's
easy to do that with and you'll always
be teetering on the edge the more time
went on I believed her performance of it
and so it didn't feel like too much to
me cuz I just had this weird go hey I'm
evil clearly and she played it like she
didn't think she was evil or like she
didn't know it's a good point she's a
good point actually so I I did like
crying Jerry fine and Mia she was good
too I wasn't like captivated though I
didn't really care to be on a journey
with her I was like I was more
interested in like let's get back to Tom
Hiddleston it with it what's going on
with him she does a good job but she is
a poor girl sort of stranded in this
situation and so the action of the
pleasant give her tons to do mostly
things happen to her in this movie she
gets swept up into situations ghosts
freak her out people were you know
messing with her in various ways or
telling her what to do and she sort of
along for this ride she hasn't given a
lot of like action action till the end
you know action to take and I didn't
really think about this until chris
stuckmann said it but she really doesn't
have much of an arc I'm not one of those
people who's like there needs to be a
huge character arc I'm not but when i
watch the film like that's probably one
of the things that was on appeal
to me was the fact that there wasn't
really a character change like I didn't
feel a growth really come out of this I
feel like she may have shrunken I mean
it's that sort of thing where they talk
about it in the movie where a ten again
I'm not gonna give away the speech but
it's basically instead of arcing she
almost four fits certain things and and
goes that way and becomes a more you
know descends yeah it becomes a more
passive character in her own life the
violence in it there's some really
gruesome violence in this film like
cringe-worthy stuff and I remember
watching it going ok the first violin
scene I was like oh yeah it's very
caught off-guard yes an honorary elicit
effective and it works yeah it's
realistic to and then that's often start
because we're not used to seeing that
but as the movie progressed I was like
was there really a need for that but
then and then I'm so back and forth of
the violence yeah because at times I was
feeling like this is just gratuitous
it's unnecessary I'm not even grossed
out anymore like especially in the
finale when the violence really starts
happening like that's when we even in
there I was like okay that was a little
too much like I'm not even gross i'm
just like that's too much but then I
also go back thinking about that first
really violent scene and how that adds
to adding an underlying horror tone yeah
like creepy suspicious tone mysterious
vibe throughout the whole film it hits
home so like you really care that
somebody is brought to justice for this
yeah and it's you know and it's a real
villain we don't know who it's like it
shows you it does arrive me a Pan's
Labyrinth when you see the bad guy in it
like beat someone's fate like just with
the back of a gun and beat him to death
and just pummel his face yeah that's a
great scene for me because I'm like that
shows just the nature and how violent
this villain is yeah and what he's
willing to do to you I'm wedding and
when they treat it in a realistic way it
does catch yeah it hurts you it's not
like enjoyable gore but it's detailed
and it's kind of artistic or the same
floor it's it's weird gamble de toros
violence since it still have an art even
to the makeup design when someone's cut
up or stabbed or her in that sense I did
like the violence because it did always
got me I was always doing like whenever
that happened
I'm talking about specifically that
first violent scene because it added a
layer of tension yeah because it's a big
mystery as to who did it even though we
all have our theories we don't really
know who did it yet even when they
reveal it kind of predictable but wait
but still it's it's not it does set up a
good tone yeah where you're like oh [ __ ]
if this vet bad guy decides to kill our
main character or someone we know he's
gonna do it anyway it'll be gruesome
yeah we bad the trailer and the
advertising emphasizes the things that
are that are more spare about this movie
if it advertised it like a gothic
romance I think I feel like the ghost in
the violent moments would all work
better because we're not expecting them
all the time so then they'll catch you
off guard and work I think properly yeah
when that first violent scene kicks in
your sort of prep for okay now things
are taken off and then we go back to
what the movie is really about which is
the Gothic story yeah I feel like this
is one of those movies that'll be much
more appreciated down the road yeah yeah
once we can ya get some distance and the
first time I watch it my first reaction
was I kind of sucked but as time has
gone on and the more I think about and
talk about it I like it more and more
yeah and I mean I think it's you go get
it more right yeah you get it more you
understand what he's going for in
hindsight you know Guerra modo Toro is
an earnest filmmaker he has a very
genuine spirit behind his movies and
that does a lot of good for you know
thinking back and you know like i said
this to you afterwards i feel like this
movie would work really well as a book
yeah it would be a great book I don't
think you even have to change that much
on the positive side it's you know it's
everyone said this the set design is
gorgeous the acting is really good the
costumes are incredible the ghost
designs when they're there are
breathtaking Hiddleston team seems to
get a lot of praise to ya Tom
Hiddleston's great you know it's it's
got all the things you love about a del
Toro movie and when the creature goes
things from a belt or a movie are in
there there's still as creepy as ever oh
yeah they're great those those isolated
moments are fantastic that's the thing
there's so much awesome stuff about this
movie and it's just whether or not
you're going to connect to the core to
the driving element and I just really
like that something like this exists i'm
so glad he got to do
this and I hope it does well just so
that he can continue to do this because
even if this movie doesn't ultimately
succeed even if over the passage of time
it's still not one of the best in his
catalog I'm still really happy he made
it i'm still really happy i saw it it
still feels like it's the film he wanted
to be anyway guys rating time grating
time I give it five out of five nipple
chills do these ratings mean anything no
oh that's my point good good to know you
don't your rating listen I'm trying to
hook more females into this channel
uh-huh so what I'm doing is I'm gonna
act like I'm not interested in them so
that way it'll get their attention so
yeah if your girls are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you know if you want to who
knows you could check out reasons to
Jerry like he cares I do i do care you
do care that's why you don't a [ __ ] and
I'm you go on facebook we're on facebook
instagram twitter vine and periscope and
i'll do a shout-out to the ladies what's
up [ __ ] oh I'm sorry were you
offended I don't care Oh [ __ ] up dude
you're talking to dude this is how you
get girls to subscribe you act like a
dick act like you're not interested and
because you're emotionally unavailable
they're going to come after you